je reçois donc que ce soir sur le
plateau michel boucherie mon sort à vos
soi merci d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation vous êtes justement atteint
par cette maladie génétique qui est la
maladie génétique est la plus répandue
en france dont elle fait 2000 décès par
an c'est le chiffre d'ailleurs de cette
édition 2000 décès par an elle concerne
une personne sur 300 voiliers pourtant
elle est très mal connue les genres et
s'expliquer mais les gens ne le savent
pas par manque d'information et un
manque d'information évident
l'hémochromatose il faut dire ce que
sait déjà c'est le un taux de fer
supérieur à la normale dans le sang ce
faire il se dépose sur le coeur ce
supplément de fer se dépose sur le coeur
sur le foie dans les articulations
alors les premiers symptômes sont des
douleurs ou os x ou d'une fatigue
générale des douleurs aux articulations
c'est ce qui m'est arrivé à moi ils ont
va découvert mon l'hémochromatose à 61
ans
vous avez découvert il ya une dizaine
d'années découvertes à quelles occasions
comme n'est pas parce que j'avais mal
j'avais mal au foie ce sont ces
symptômes qui voit la rareté jumelles au
fois j'ai eu mon médecin traitant m'a
fait passer tout un tas de l'examen du
fois j'avais absolument rien et après il
a pensé à l'hémochromatose et il m'a
fait faire une piste de st et ça s'est
avéré
j'avais 2700 et mg de fer au lieu de 294
maximum aujourd'hui 27 mai débute une
semaine de sensibilisation is te ment
pour informer la population autour de
cette somme maladie génétique mais la
connaissez vous justement c'est la
question que nous sommes allez vous
poser aujourd'hui c'est notre question
du genre connaissez-vous les micros
matos ah non pas du tout une maladie
chromatique couleur sanguine
ah non pas du tout pas du tout ça me
parle pas de parler des aliments non non
ça ne vaut rien du tout non non je veux
avoir un rapport avec les couleurs mais
à part ça de plantes et notre matos une
maladie du sang voilà qui concerne les
globules rouges avec des faits en tant
que je me souvienne et vous faire des
ponctions puis des pics saigner comme
dans le temps alors donné une dernière
personne qui était plutôt renseigner un
sort ce monsieur est donc été saigné
d'ailleurs juste ce monsieur ce monsieur
a raison il n'ya pas il ya aucun
médicament c'est exclusivement des
saignées vous faire des saignées
régulière par ce qui vous concerne
alors moi maintenant j'ai pu stabiliser
je suis stabilisé mon taux de ça au
départ jallet toutes les semaines
d'aviron de retirer 400 grammes toutes
les semaines de sang maintenant ça s'est
stabilisé
j'en suis à 100 86 seigner et je suis je
suis stabilisé je tourne autour de 100
100 mg c'est normal quoi que vous
exerciez les médecins qu'il n'y a aucun
traitement et qu'il n'y a là aussi aucun
traitement en cours d'élaboration
il ya des études qui sont faites il ya
eu des des médicaments ont été pour été
mise en pratique mais ça ne faisait ça a
détraqué ailleurs la peine il ya eu
vraiment que les saignées alors le
principe de la saignée c'est que on vous
retire du sang qui est polluée par le
fait et le corps faisant du nouveau sans
dépôt des pôles urnes et polluent le
le sens qui est actuellement avec les
branches et vous dans le corps et après
ma foi c'est sa rosace et pratiquer ou
au départ c'était tous les huit jours
maintenant je vais tous les deux mois
nous allons nous rendre à
l'établissement français du sang c'est
au chesnay jeu social je vais montrer là
vous vous rendez c'est là où se rendait
les malades nous avons rencontré à une
autre personne atteinte par cette sale
maladie génétique
voilà a lui aussi son quotidien
reportage catherine gélato elodie moines
gratuite tous les trois mois
gwenaëlle bénard seront à
l'établissement français du sang au
chesnay aujourd'hui on lui prélève 450
millilitres un traitement unique et
indispensable pour sa pathologie
car le jeune homme est atteint
d'hémochromatose c'est-à-dire un excès
de fer dans le son c'est la première
maladie génétique de france gt banc un
peu plus de trois mois où je leur mets
très peu et très mal donc
à force de voir des médecins et
finalement le médecin de famille qui de
bretagne qui a eu l'idée de faire
analyser mon père mais c'est là qu'on a
découvert que j'avais un taux de série
teen très élevé s'il vous plaît les
agrès pour être touchés par cette
maladie il faut avoir hérité de deux
gènes provenant l'un du père l'autre de
la mer donc si on n'a pas ces deux gènes
on n'a pas la maladie
donc finalement il ya assez peu de
chance de l'avoir mais on a suffisamment
pour que ça soit effectivement la
première mais mali génétique en france
gwenaëlle a découvert sa maladie il ya
deux ans et si la pathologie n'est pas
traitée rapidement le faire peut se
déposer sur les organes tels que le foie
et générer des tumeurs
d'où la nécessité de pratiquer ce que
l'on appelle des saignées la plus grande
partie des réserves de l'organisme enfer
se trouve dans les globules rouges et
donc on conçoit bien que si on fait des
c n'est donc on va retirer une partie
des globules rouges et bien l'organisme
va se defendre va réagir en synthétisant
d'autres globules rouges pour remplacer
ceux qu'on a retirés et pour fabriquer
ces nouveaux globules rouges
il va puiser en priorité dans les
organes qui sont surchargés en faire
c'est comme ça que l'on peut obtenir
petit à petit une des saturations de
l'organisme en faire donc c'est un terme
qui peut paraître un peu obsolète la
saignée mais non on n'a pas trouvé mieux
parce que ça dit bien ce que ça veut
dire
les symptômes peuvent être trompeurs
forte fatigue douleurs musculaires
troubles sexuels assigne de diabète ou
encore faible densité osseuse la maladie
chez les femmes se déclarent plutôt à la
ménopause
en france une personne sur 300 et
porteuses du gène déficient une semaine
nationale de sensibilisation se déroule
jusqu'au 1er juin
nous évoquons donc ce soir pour débuter
cette édition du 7 8 ans ce 27 semaines
nous évoquons l'hémochromatose est la
première maladie génétique en france
2000 décès par an une personne sur 300
concernés dans l'hexagone c'est moins ce
soir pour nous expliquer son quotidien
vous nous expliquer comme l'autre
personne que nous avons découvert à
travers ce reportage que la saignée
était la seule solution de la seule
solution
une fois que la ceni est effectuée vous
vivez normalement je vis là absolument
normalement ce qu'il faut faire
attention à ce que vous mangez par
exemple d'aider des lentilles qui est
beaucoup de fer faut éviter l'alcool
évidemment il faut si vous buvez à
l'apéritif de temps en temps c'est pas
ça qui va vous faire remonter le temps
le taux de fer il faut quand même se
surveiller mais pas manger n'importe
quoi et moi maintenant je me sens je me
sens bien quoi l'essentiel cdj stage
jusqu'à maintenant une dizaine d'années
mais on peut faire un dépistage à partir
de quand roger bossard l'est pour les
hommes - la trentaine
la trentaine et à quelque chose qui est
curieux c'est que l'on retrouve beaucoup
de gens contre les mots creux bateau ce
sont des gens de la bretagne la bretagne
et beaucoup touché et le paie le sud de
la france du côté de béziers perpignan
etc
on parle d'une maladie celtique et
d'ailleurs il faudra là aussi précisé
qu'il faut que les deux parents soient
porteurs voilà qu ensuite leur vie moi
dans ma famille que je n'avais jamais
entendu parler d'hémochromatose savoir
ont été porteurs mais porteurs sains et
j'ai pas personne je suis tombé des nues
je renonce et ça je connaissais pas
j'étais comme les gens qu'on a vu dans
la rue tout à l'heure ignorant
compression est ce que par la suite
justement maintenant une fois que vous
avez eu cette information vous l'avez
communiquer votre entourage vous en a
bien sûr j'ai dit à mes enfants de faire
le faire des prises de sang et se faire
contrôler ils l'ont fait ils ont ri ri
ont de la chance ils ne font rien pour
le moment il reste porteur centre de
voile à de cette maladie est jeune et il
faut il faut dire que les femmes
souvent touché après la ménopause ce qui
est effectivement précisant dans le
reportage se sont plutôt épargnées par
cette épargne et le temps que les ont
leur l'horizon le sens enfin après sympa
mais après ils risquent de faire de
avoir trop de faire aujourd'hui vous
témoigner vous vous impliquez justement
auprès de l'association pour communiquer
autour de cette maladie que vous avez
découvert très tard louis jeu de dés le
départ j'ai associé au siège à animaux
là je suis adhérent du siège à nîmes là
et j'ai déjà fait une émission de
télévision à ce sujet la venue ce soir
témoigne et merci à vous je rappelle que
nous sommes en pleine semaine de
sensibilisation qu'il ya plusieurs
opérations notamment à travers l'île de
france que ce soit meulan attrape il ya
un site internet hémochromatose point fr
afin d'en savoir plus merci à vous vous
souhaitez être quelque chose à
l'occasion d'une visite chez le médecin
demandez à votre propre fils saad de
faire un contrôle de plus faire une
prise de sang pour voir si vraiment le
dépistage est très simple existe et
simple voilà c'était de quoi
effectivement alone et ne pas attendre
il aurait fallu que je sache que j'avais
sa mère peu avant
merci à vous l'ancienne boucherie d'être
venu donc témoigner sur ce plan donne